in the air
on land
and at sea
the nigerian military is under strict
orders to end the plundering of the
country's oil
when security forces returned to the
site they destroyed five weeks earlier
they encountered oil thieves
as troops chased them
the vandals
ran towards their boats
hidden in the creeks
one is captured
in terms of crushing these
illegal refining sites we have crushed
thousands of them
as you are destroying one side before
you get to the other one another one is
springing up again
this pipeline is one of the most
frequently vandalized in the country
it delivers half a million barrels of
oil a day to an export terminal but for
the past five months not a drop was
delivered as the operator shell was
forced to shut it down
we've had stations where
when we're going to
cooking camps irs camps like this
they've set fire to the camps you know
endangering
us and
our equipment
most of the stolen crude is ferry to
larger vessels at sea by barges like
these which are usually hard to
apprehend
flying over the creeks the devastation
caused by all bunkering is massive
hidden under tree canopies the oil
thieves are putting finishing touches to
this facility capable of refining tens
of thousands of gallons a day
and instead of using firewood
they now steal gas to distill the crude
military commanders say there are
hundreds of these illegal distilleries
scattered across the oil producing delta
in addition to bleeding the economy dry
the operations also damage the
environment because they are not
properly equipped to process crude oil
the plant of nigeria's oil has left the
country unable to meet its opec quarter
activities are going on as i'll speak to
you now
so much collaboration going with the
communities to make sure that they're
also involved in the project of
protecting these assets
the company looks up to the renewed
climb down to return to profitability
but with all thieves continuously
changing their tactics it could be a
long while before that will happen
ahamad idris al jazeera in nigeria is
all producing delta